the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu so come out and then this is
micah and we work together on a
framework for flexible stream processing
on the cell so we were also oriented
towards an application which is in this
case is software radio and we use this
application as a case study where's the
mic and speakers not as i can so our
project was about flexible flexible
stream processing framework for the cell
and we use the software radio as an as a
case study essentially of an application
we could build using this framework the
motivation for our project is
essentially what we've been discussing
in class has been reiterated the cell
isn't easy to program there is no shared
memory there's just message passing
which is quite messy you have to
explicitly paralyze your programs if you
want to write them as say custom C
programs some of the groups have
described the challenges they faced when
doing that extracting parallelism can be
tricky for example if you want to do
pipelining then on the ESPYs you have to
predict what addresses you are going to
require and set up the dms or at those
addresses are fetched in advance and as
bill mentioned in his talk in class
stream programming can help alleviate
some of these issues for some
applications like software radio where
the applications fit naturally into the
streaming model so what we try to do for
our project was build a lightweight as
lightweight as possible because the code
has to fit on the STS but as expressive
as possible as well so as to simplify
life for developers the streaming
framework which is targeted specifically
at signal processing applications so
this is based on the data model at least
is based on research project that I have
worked on in the past which is wave
scope streaming database management
system is a research project in the
database group the data model is
essentially an extension of the
streaming model to hand
larger blocks of data so as to process
them better example 7 signal processing
operators like the fast Fourier
transform need to do multiple passes
over the data and therefore trying to
treat streams on a sample by sample
basis leads to high cost scheduling
overhead as well as inefficiency so
that's why the data model does and we
tried to put this data model over to the
Cell processor and see how well we could
exploit the features of the Cell
processor in particular the high on chip
bandwidth between the ESPYs to do
streaming so our case study was as we
mentioned a simple software radio
application it's really simple uses
incoherent demodulation as well as this
simple amplitude shift keying modulation
as i said the main goals of a framework
would simplify life as much parallelism
as possible try and extract pipeline
parallelism data parallelism some of the
kinds of parallelism bill mentioned the
kind of columns we were able to finally
implement so far only pipeline
parallelism but as future work could be
interested in the other kinds of
parallels in as well more about it as I
go on so in our in the framework we at
least implemented the programming model
is quite simple the basic execution unit
is what we call an operator it's
analogous to what instrument would be
called a work function or what in kannur
radio which is the framework for
building software use radios would be
called a block so these operators can be
any arbitrary C++ classes with state and
they implement an iterate method which
the developer has to overload in order
to process a block of data the way scope
data model also provides a library for
managing memory and passing blocks of
signal data between these operators
applications in this model are built by
chaining operatives together so this is
a snippet of some other code we wrote
for the software radio roughly so you
create a box let's say filter which
processes elements of type float and
then it takes and some arguments
initialize the filters parameters and so
on you want to create a white noise
generator and hook up the filter to the
white noise generator we use this to
simulate a simple Channel Five's channel
so I'll just describe the competence of
a framework
we have a lightweight scheduler on both
the PPE as well as the ESPYs right now
to use the static operator mapping in
the sense that you have to specify
static configuration file where you say
this operator name will run on this SP
SP 0 number but we will not completely
implemented dynamically reconfiguring it
at runtime and we haven't yet seen the
need for doing that so it wouldn't be
too hard to add if needed but right now
you can easily shuffle around the
operator mapping by tweeting the
configuration file signal blocks as I
said we're adapted from wave scope they
use a reference counting and avoid
in-memory copies which can be quite
expensive especially on the cell the
brawls provide a convenient API to
manipulate signals so you don't have to
do much of the memory management to
yourself or debug any of the heart
problems to do with memory management we
also quoted this library to ensure that
data is a line for you automatically and
transported where queues so one of the
major things we had to implement was a
queuing library and a remote heat
management what amounted essentially to
a remote heap management library so in
some sense we faced a choice here we
could either have the PPE control and
allocate memory statically and make all
the decisions about what memory is
allocated where or we could have the
ESPYs manage it themselves we decided to
go for the latter partly because it was
more dynamic and also because we weren't
sure what the implications of all the
control flow passing through the PPE
were for this so we chose the second
approach which is autonomous memory
management so when an SP sends a
streaming data element to another SP it
can it doesn't have to actually
explicitly request the other SP for
allocating memory it has a remote heap
interface so that it can directly
allocate data and right to the ESB this
is currently of fixed size but it could
be improved by using this heap to share
a bunch of cues right now we have one
remote heap for each queue between
operators on different ESPYs so our
system automatically handles pipelining
and streaming data from SP to SP using
the DMA API
so Micah will take over from here and
describe the software radio
implementation briefly either stay on
the side where the phone is our
okay so so our software radio
implementation is is relatively simple
we were we were pushing on that to hurt
especially because it took the vast
majority over time just to get the
framework to work saving the program or
trouble meant that we inherited a lot of
trouble ourselves so it breaks down into
about 25 25 boxes which which we are
config file which is manually Matt Matt
Matt to back to the a to the SPS about
about three thousand lines of code most
of which is most of which is framework
so I guess if we're worth put together
we'd have a nice diagram to show you i
will as enough time i'll try to draw a
quick diagram on the chalkboard so we're
simulant we're simulating both sender
receiver and a channel so so that this
is so the the computation in question
looks something like you have a bit
stream you need to take these and
convert them into some can you get
anything
all right lovely all right um so you
tinker stream of bits in um take it's um
basically sorry so use a lookup
mechanism to convert it to an analog
waveform and filter that to produce
something that has a narrower spectrum
and so you get you know you probably see
pictures visits in it's very much like
a.m. it's basically binary a is this
gaming license one of the simplest do
okay then this is set to simulate a
channel which is a random furfle to
finite impulse response so it's
basically what that means just basically
it's taking the copies of the input at
different time offsets with random
random coefficients and just selling
them up so huge multiply add multiply
add so 80 this is a teat apps and add
some Gaussian noise
and in this we take over and then try to
figure out what we put it in the first
place so bunch of filtering again more
more fighting equals response filtering
we have to there's a little closed loop
that tries to escalate signal amplitude
and correct for it that's called
automatic gain control to sort of keep
it constant and I'm probably getting
things these things a little out of
order we square the signal this is the
incoherent demodulation for every square
the signal get rid of the carrier
automatic gain control filtering another
loop just called a phase lock loop the
idea is try to match a sine wave to some
to some to some input signal so explain
it very well it's basically a locking
type of detector the idea is to lock
into the phase of some periodic thing
this is recovering when do you sample
because you've got this messy way forget
know when when to look and say okay is
it high is it low to get it right now
yeah all right let's I think that gives
a picture I'm probably boring everybody
so your picture here's a picture
generators in the system on the red line
so the green line is the data and the
red line is the emotional out right
before it's supposed to decide what the
heck the input was so this is after just
after exactor squaring filtering an
automatic gain control and all that the
whom blitz are actually because we use
squeezed am modulation called alternate
mark inversion which basically flips
everyone that's why flipping instead of
eight
and then the little blue gathers are the
results of the phase-locked loop they're
trying to cover wait to sample my kind
of off with a good right and so if you
take the little blue blue blip if the
red line is above zero it's a one and
it's below zero and that's how you get
your pits out so this was hard to hear
right mostly because of the framework
issues so we know implementing
implementing distributed objects on a
system without real shared memory it's
hard because you have to serialize
everything into a stream of bits and
deserialize so it really makes pie out
of any existing object oriented code we
we did put a bit of work to get good you
get sort of decent lock free almost zero
copy of another day or so we graduated
got zero copy transfer transfer
streaming of the data from place to
place and we had to keep the code fruit
print low C++ is bloated we don't have
an overlay system yet to sort of you
know if if SPE is not running a
particular box it's that the code for it
so they don't have you know we don't
have any infrastructure for some macros
yeah it's pretty messy so all the code
is on all the lcds so code bloat is
particularly issue and xlc has this
particular penchant for runtime type
information and exception handling the
incredible amount of Voodoo is necessary
to get the map to get them in that 70 k
of useless bloat out of there but we
pretty much have it it works but not
always so measurements yeah we did get
we did get some decent data out running
only through and vice with the
scheduling file that sort of kind of
rule of thumb we just sort of roughly
said okay that looks about this they
will throw it on this espe espe espe
using minus vgs lodge yeah we had to
really had to push down things like a
cute we just didn't have that memory
yeah basically
it's an interesting interesting
performance behavior we found that the
sdes are ridiculously underutilized
there may be the most of the algorithms
are quite a bit zippier on the STS and
so if you know there may be running
about a third of the time or and the
rest of the time just waiting for input
and then the PPE which is still be only
a tiny amount of the computation basis
just leading in and sucking it out is
spending half of its time all busy and
the other half of the time stuck in flow
control waiting for Q space which we are
flow control algorithm sucks and better
with time but so but it seems like you
should be able to do quite a bit better
than we did with a bit more work
so okay we need to cut down to the code
footprint and once we have a little bit
of breathing room we can and get rid of
the nasty race bugs and such we can
finally investigate what was our sort of
original pie-in-the-sky goal of
automatically deciding what goes where
you know doing taking measurements of
the performance and then feeding that
back into to producing a better
placement of operators and applying data
parallelism by instantiating operators
on multiple multiple different SP ES and
splitting the data stream and just doing
more so we did with some work on there
actually put work on there because we
couldn't fit all the boxes the code for
all the boxes under the sb's so we sort
of strategically put a few things in the
beating of using yet which weren't
supposed to be very computationally
intensive and yet they managed to take
up half the CPU the issue the issue with
the other half of the CPU is that it's
actually in inside an inner loop deep
recursive in blocking because basically
our back pressure isn't online yet so if
it if if it tries to admit something to
a queue and the queue is full just
stomps and it really could be running
over other stuff but it's not smart to
do that
everything being everything being unlike
sort of a model extreme it everything
here is sort of asynchronous and code
driven or sort of gas tease they can
cite and fly how much you may prefer
business Clary it means everything
singers and so grace raised additional
or put in this application you find any
dynamic rate in this implication is not
much it's a very simple obligation who
recommends a package ization o error
correction compression things like that
privacy yeah this is definitely
underutilized is in the case of the
radio we're going to be okay to talk may
be afraid of audio data just because you
know you're spending so much time
waiting and be better just to know
relieve the pressure on the cube by just
dropping some pressure necessary in
plainwell interpolating in the end try
to fix it up it might well be we decided
not to do that as a perfect framework
because policy decisions do you want to
make that for all possible applications
but if you figure out a good way to
expose dat
drop with doctors so what about buffer
sizes you declare the buffer size as
well uh yeah well the way we have it now
except traditions kind of defined me but
that says all buffers are this size
double buffering in there you don't need
it well actually the way it works is
that there's this or this remote heat
input queue and an upstream SP just game
these things in as it feels like and
then the the downstream SPE looks is
there something here grab it use it so
it just it just it just sort of works
however much buffering guess that that's
that's an that's a benefit of the
asynchronous approach she just sort of
works if you have enough memory which we
don't accuse our tiny angrily Telemundo
his connection to drop
yeah I can see
and the other question did you want to
do the dough how do you manage to get
ourselves race conditions well its a mix
of the fact that all the SPU's can
essentially operate as independent
threads and our sort of asynchronously
DM aying thanks to each other and some
somewhat poor user legacy driven
architectural decisions on the way to be
in code works because we poured a lot of
code from the waves to go platform or
doesn't clearly available yeah and that
was intended to be multi threaded with P
threads which you know in our original
naive before we actually started the
class impression we've got your support
I don't think of these P threads on the
set which of course is not possible so
there were still some threaded
components in there and we introduced a
lot of bugs trying to blow the sudden
surprising thing was the fact that we
had to replace array constructors in
order to eliminate rtti and it is a big
things I really knew we had to get rid
of to leave we had to get rid of great
constructors we have to get rid of
virtual the struggle rational functions
and virtue instructors or mess but I
guess one is is one more give you a
negative based initiatives it's
incredible how many subtle race
conditions and bugs be found in the
queuing the remote even killing library
because there's 11 it's a log frames a
lot of reason for this data structure
there are two two threads to to st was
reading and writing from it at the same
time and there's all sorts of the
subtleties where if you get a little bit
wrong you end up with one
keep orders over running the other guy
and he had basically dangling pointers
and things like that at least three or
four times we spent a few hours until we
discovered that was the cause of
mysterious behavior